все нові зробить шумів не колега але
ті ж душі круто вийшло я хочу
поляків цієї європейської солідарності
потім фантастичною ініціатива пакистаном
інстанція я хочу хлопця кого ти голос ту
ж круто колимі обнявшись робимо таки
мова я хочу панікувати і батьківщину як
дав обітницю пасі активно включилася в
боротьбу за ту ж липкими погавкаю я хочу
потягуватися за мій будь не панікує їжа
віру і михай бог простить поляків цього
пожирає я дикую цих змі нафти з
фракції слуга народу я ті піт поставив і
bitmos ще стала дала нам потрібні звістка
прийняти і панував
свердлити увагу ми говоримо про не просять
чарку води переконаний на не просять
тину за 3 мг і води intel ми говоримо про
просять ремка воду води ну за одну робину
опоки в ціну залі у вселенську померла
30 українців померли через без
діяльності
чемпіона світу по боротьбі з коронавірусом
по нам за ленську змінюйте 3 міністр
оборони огрош і йдуть на рани як родіон
це шок валізою та замети 5 лікарів
коронку вати владу
закуповується
машини для закиїв готова щоб боротися
за позицію
вимикається кішки на будь все
Аліна брати bus коронавірусом лікарів на
місця чаю я твердо прикольні самим а
йому дорогі друзі продовжити цю
практику келихи ми об'єкту та мася у нас
всі виходи та оксани за раз об'єднуємося
я думаю ще будуть вже важливі ваші б про
slide кого ти ціни за цими купаються
станції але я дуже добрий пам'ятаю шакали
мейбл audi емі понд купувати з нього
концентрату по 20 25 тисяч гривень
їх купівля лапу 39 до роду чикиш ти
теслярі подарунки і він же кішки платити
їм подарунки в я назву чайна важливі
модему он з є коли приколи
подарунки платяться а my favorites вона в
сварях від того ж будемо вузли його щоб
наріжте у корів україни та парламент від
рима у вигляді а звідки
шликів ти зеленому в офшорній
компанії чому windows їм учасникам
традишці врослими вибивання грошей ніж у
веж та порушені кримінально праворуч та
чому тут якісь gone when i святий
Анни буду і святого ти буду заздрити
ермак буду збитого ті мін дичину будуть
кольору від і емші особ